All right. Can you hear? Okay good.
All right. Well, I want to say thank you. First of all for allowing me
to be absent last week. We had a
very peaceful home going of my father-in-law and
he was a believer in Jesus and I had
an opportunity in 2010 to talk with him
through the concept of security in
Salvation. And he said
he was involved in a religious
experience where he believed that you could
lose your salvation and I was able to show him in Scripture
that that that's really kind of out of our hands that
God is able to save us completely forever
and there's nothing we do to deserve
it and there's nothing we can do to out earn it
and we don't earn it at all. So anyway, so
I know he was a Believer and we had a great service. I'll
tell you a funny I didn't see this
coming. But while we were sitting with the family, it's
a very trepidation experience
to be the
Efficient of the service and the
son-in-law simultaneously and so we're
planting the service and right at the end we find out from his
new wife.
That they would go to the Opry on Friday nights
and seeing uh Bluegrass and
southern gospel music and and they
they would always finish with I'll Fly
Away, you know some glad morning. And so and then
what really moved me is that they would
sing it together as a couple on the way to the car or the
parking lot. So I said don't you think it would be good if we
sang that to finish his service on Saturday and
she said like yeah, that'd be great. And then
it hits me. I've I don't lead music.
This could go really poorly and what a
way to ruin a great service but what you
didn't know is that a lot of people from the Opry were there and a lot
of folks from the Church of Christ were there and so we crushed
all fly away. I wanted to sing
second verse but didn't do it. So anyway, but thank
you for allowing me to be gone and thank you Pastor John
for coming and serving. Well, we're in chapter 10 this week and
we're going to since we got
started a little bit late. We're gonna forgo the pathway, of course,
you know the pathways that we're always in movement.
We're not satisfied with worship alone. Of
course, we worship it's a command of God a
mandate we obey but we also want to be involved in
the community group and open group where there's Bible study
and just bible discussion. But what we're learning is
that the most optimal place the space for
most successful and fruitful disciple making
is in a micro group because it's a gender specific
and we maintain
A size last week you may
have discussed. I'm not sure since it
wasn't here. You may have discussed the optimal experience
of the micro group and how it might be different
from the
it's not going to work, but how it
might be different from one on one and
both are an excellent way of making disciples,
but we
We believe that the micro group
or the D group is optimal because of attrition.
If one person can't be there in a
one-on-one relationship. That means the meeting is over and you
can actually have an absence and in
a micro group and then continue in the right direction. And
so that's one reason why and then
another reason why is that I don't
want to I don't want anybody get discouraged because
I'm not okay our first night ten weeks
ago. We had 207 people. Okay, and here
we are 10 weeks later and with about half that
I think we're doing better than half tonight. And I want to say way to
go. Those are either been gone. No judgment glad to have you back. But
anyway attrition happens life
happens disciple making
is a command of God and so you can expect some spiritual
resistance from our
adversary and attrition happens, but this way these
are these groups
Are large enough to continue but small enough so that
we can we can check in on one another we can
know one another and we can sense where a
person is in their Spiritual Development
or formation. Okay, hopefully last week
John talked to you a little bit about the ecclesi Ecclesiastes pasties
passage two are better than one.
And then also we ought we talked about the two
expectations the intentional leader right now.
Y'all pray for me. I'm working on an addition
to our church website that you can click on
a button saying I want to be a disciple maker and or
I want to join a disciple making
group and so in doing so we
can get your name and get you matched up with someone but an
intentional leader is responsible for Gathering
their own group, and I've been asking you to pray diligently
about who would I ask to
be in my micro group because you're going to invest your
life and you're gonna spend time should be someone that you you
love and someone that you know, and someone that you
are excited about spending time going deeper with and
so hopefully you're doing that but
one of the things that an intentional leader does is model
scriptural engagement. All
right each disciple in the micro.
Was going to be learning biblical content and
responding to that content in a
group but it's more than information. It's transformation. That
means is is that we're going to challenge one
another in a micro group to be studying the same
content. Maybe we'll talk
about curriculum in a minute maybe a curriculum that you've
decided on but maybe just a book of the Bible depending on
the makeup of your group and you'll be studying it
together once a week, but you'll be studying individually
daily. And what we're trying to do
is establish a regular repeated a
habit of scriptural engagement
more than just Bible reading but Bible engagement.
What does this say? What did
it say to the original hearers? What does it say about God? What does
it say about me? How should I respond?
Into it to what it is saying and so it's an
engagement issue where each disciple knows
that we are here for my spiritual growth
and in each disciple also
knows that when I grow to a certain point it
is the expectation that I will then become
the intentional leader and Lead my own group. So
the last week John talked about
how the intentional leader understands that curriculum is only
a tool.
Tools are only as good as
the person who knows how to use them.
All right, and some of you are very good at certain tools others
in the same room would say what is this thing? What
does it do? Right but once you've learned how to use it, I've done
something for you that I have no expectations as far
as what kind of curriculum you use but because
we didn't have anything like this. I went ahead and
engaged a nav press and that purchased 10
copies of growing in Christ. I've been through this
I don't know about a dozen times with brand new
Christians. Remember Carol when they were P Green and they had a
little squirrely Tree on the front. Anyway, this is
what it looks like. Now, it looks good, but it's
just the basics of disciple making
and I'm not expecting you
to buy your curriculum from the bookstore but I put them
in the bookstore so that you will know that it's available. You can look at it.
You can decide what you like and then you can order it online. So you don't
exhaust the bookstore. I bought 10 copies that's about two and
a half micro groups. All right. The other thing
that I bought was 10 copies of this two seven series. Also a
Navigator's curriculum has the book one book
two and book three again just covers
kind of the essentials of a brand new
Christian. So if you have a brand new Christian in your group, then you're probably
going to want to maybe use something that's going
to help them get started on the right on the right track. All
right.
And then intentional leaders model
expectations for transparency in your book
Jill Wagner has given you
one of these cards and this is going to be one of the most
important cards in your discipleship experience. Okay?
The reason is is that on one side is the
micro group Covenant and I would suggest
that once you have your micro group identified,
whether it's three or four people that you look at
this Covenant together and you seriously go over each line so
that they can know what is expected of
them. What's going to be expected of them and then you can sign it
in front of one another and date it and then you're not
turning it into me. There's no micro group
Covenant Police Department. All right,
this is just you Covenant with one another that we
are going to study God's word together. We're gonna go deeper together.
We expect to pray for one another we're
going to be involved in the scriptures together. You'll see
what things are in the Covenant but on the other side is
this we've not spent a lot of time on this, but I
wanted to give you a copy of it. These are really helpful guidelines
for every micro group and what
that means. Is that what you will learn
as you read this is that some of
In this room on Wednesday night have stepped outside
the guidelines. Okay, for example, let's
just look at number one a confidentiality.
Now was said in the group stays in the group and hopefully
no one's experienced a brief breach of confidentiality. But
here's a two important ones pause and
silence.
We have agreed that the holy spirit is the teacher. And so
if you ask a good question, and then
you wait for a response, it's okay to have
a moment of silence.
Even better is when a person is sharing and
they get to a point where they may have arrived at
a painful experience or a convicting
experience and they stop as a result of their emotional
condition. It's okay
to sit there and wait.
What a lot of leaders will do and myself included is I'm
not uncomfortable with somebody being uncomfortable. So I'll just jump right
in there and say, oh I'm so sorry. You don't have to talk anymore or the
dreaded give them a clean X, you
know, like hair stop that crying, you know,
but we'll wait we'll pause we'll
listen because that's when the Holy Spirit does
some of his best work. Okay, what's another
no cross talk that means there's a
conversation going on. That's not the primary conversation
more than one conversation going on at once and then
no fixing or rescuing. That means
is that Jesus does the fixing what we're
just what we're doing is we're having scriptural conversations
letting the Holy Spirit do his work and
letting the Holy Spirit lead us to conclusions for transform
behavior. All right. This takes the
onus of responsibility of you being the
the the hierarchical know-it-all
Okay, you're not the the teacher that knows let
me tell you what you need to do on that now. That's that's not
what this opposite is.
And then this last one is what I wanted to get to sharing.
I'm gonna read it to you. Okay, because this is going to be one of your biggest problems as
a micro group be sensitive about the amount
of time you share.
Don't be offended. If the leader asks to hear from
others typically in every group. There's
one person who does not want to share at all.
And one person who does not know when to stop sharing.
Okay, and so as a micro group,
it's okay for you to say. Hey, I like to hear from
this guy about that or this gal about that or hey
at a
guy in one of my groups. That was just very very
verbose and he and I had a plan that when I
would click my watch like this.
That it meant that he was over it. It's
time for him to stop. Okay, and I had to do this almost the
whole meeting.
Because he loved discipleship and loved to have something to
say about discipleship. All right be self-aware how
you were affecting the environment with
your non-verbals people are busy. Sometimes
they look at their clock. Sometimes they tap
their clock. Sometimes they they have
to the check and see what's happening if
there's something happening in the room, but be self-aware that you're
nonverbals can shut somebody down. And then lastly
this is the one that I wanted to spend a little bit of time with is I
statements
Once I was walking through here on a
Wednesday night and someone said hey, can you explain to me what I statements mean?
We have a proclivity.
to
discuss things that are not about us
necessarily
Like you know what the problem with the church is.
Or you know what the problem with the culture is. The one thing about
the culture that I don't like is that we're not really here
to transform the church and we're not really here to transform the culture.
Who are we who am I here necessarily to transform?
me
so one of the one of the leaders best tools
is when a person says, you know what I
don't like about the church is this is to say
well, can you say that in the form of an eye statement?
And if they can't they shouldn't be saying it and
if they can then they get to become a part
of the transformation the solution for what's going
wrong.
All right, and it gets personal.
And it's supposed to get personal. It's supposed to be intimate that
way and so practice I statements intentional leaders
ask for eye statements. All
right, let's get to tonight's content and let me
just tell you.
I saw it coming. This is
probably the hardest hurdle for us to
to navigate and that is making the
most of your time. How do I find time to
make disciples only 24 hours in
a day.
You have to spend some of that time eating sleeping working
relating in
your family and doing the things that you like to do. And so
what I'm telling you today is that
when you're trying to find time disciple making isn't
something that you do if you have extra time.
Because your adversary understands the
power of discipleship and he'll make sure you never have
any extra time.
Okay, we're on page four here of your
handout. We must make disciple making
a priority. That's what Jesus did he
prioritized time and investing in his disciples. He
did have public Ministries with large crowd, but
he constantly demanded time with
disciples and so really quickly.
How do you do that? Will you take an inventory of your time and you
do two things that you have to do and one is
a concentrate what that means
is is that you're going to concentrate on the things in your life that are the
most important.
And you're going to eliminate.
Things in your life that are not important.
All right. And you say well everything I
do is important. Well, I don't disagree with that. But you have to prioritize to
try to make time for discipleship and number
two is was revolutionary for me and that
is and this is on page five repurpose the time you already
have here's a conversation did you eat
today?
Yes.
How many times did you eat today? That's three times others would
say two others would say six, but it's
multiple times a day. All right, you ate breakfast
lunch and dinner. Yes.
So if you eat three times a day, then you have
at least three opportunities a day to make disciples.
Why not? This is a great question. What if you
took just one meal each week?
one meal out of 21 meal times in a
week
and gave it to the Lord for the purpose of sharing a meal
and making disciples.
That's what I have been most effective.
During the week early a
one group met at six.
That's even that's even earlier than 6:30, but you
can't meet months meet much later than 6:30, because guys and
ladies have got to get a work at 7:30. If you
have retirees in your group, then you can
meet at a different pace and a different Leisure, but why not
get up early and decide somewhere
where you can meet that's going to be calm a relational environment
and and share meat meal
together Donuts. I don't
eat donuts.
But they're cheap.
And if somebody says I can't eat that. I mean I
can't meet then I'm having breakfast then. Oh, I'll bring breakfast.
Right, so just share that time together
for the purpose of making disciples repurpose the
time you have for making disciples and then the last
two of these make an appointment.
All of you as mature adults
know what it means to make time for
things that are important. All right, if I have a
heart condition and I have an appointment with the cardiologist. I'm
going to say I didn't have time to go today.
No, it's my heart. I gotta go. That's the
cardiologist right? It's important. Well, if
disciple making is important, then you have
to purpose in your heart to set an appointment with those
in your micro group. All right, make it
the first appointment for that day schedule that
appointment each week prioritize it car of
time out for it and and keep the the disciple
making appointment and also be flexible and creative.
That means is that when you meet together with
your micro group, you may discover that the time that you thought was
going to work is not going to work. And so you may have to be flexible.
I think I told you when I
was in seventh or
8th grade.
My minister of Youth came to me and asked me to pray about something about being
in this opship group. And so there was
more than a micro group there was about seven of us and and
there was no time during the
week that we could meet but we all discovered that we could meet
at seven am on Saturday morning.
And that is the last thing that
11 year old boy wants to be doing is getting up and going to
church on Saturday, too.
I knew I was coming on Sunday.
But guess what for six solid years
we met on Saturday morning.
And that's when I memorized most of the scripture that I have memorized and
that's when I fell in love with Jesus and learned how to have a Bible
engagement every day and it and
frankly. It's probably the reason
I'm standing before you today.
Is that I believe in this because I made
time for this and my minister
of Youth was creative enough to say
I'll give up a Saturday morning to meet with a group of boys who need
to see Jesus and to turn into Jesus. All right.
Really quickly. Jesus was our model.
Jesus had a micro group. Did you know this?
Peter James and John were his quad
his micro group. He asked
specifically for those three alone.
To be with him during the raising of jarius's daughter.
This is a
Page six also during the Transfiguration of
Jesus. I'm not
going to spend a lot of time on this but I love that that passage where
you know, Jesus is transfigured there
with Moses Elijah and Peter because he's a
disciple and stuff will make her goes. Hey, let's start a building
program and build a building. You know, he must have been a Baptist
don't you think and and Jesus is like
There's something else going on here.
You know, he also asked
them to be with him in a special way during
the his time in the Garden of Gethsemane. So I
don't know the answer to these questions, but these
are great questions. Maybe you can spend some time on
these questions in your micro group tonight. What conclusions can
be drawn for the reasons that Jesus had a micro
group? Why did he choose a circle of three
and himself to experience these things?
Why did Jesus arrange for intimate moments
in Ministry?
Why did he win his micro group to witness his power over
death?
Or to observe his glory revealed.
Why did Jesus want his micro group to share in the
anguish and submission in his submission of the will of
the father and Garden of Gethsemane?
I don't know the answer to this but I
do know this that all three of those men Peter
James and John had powerful leadership experiences in
the New Testament Church. You can read about it in Acts. You can
read about it in first and second Peter. You can read about it in
John in Revelation. You can read about it. All through James was
the the leader of the Jewish Church in Jerusalem Post
Resurrection. So all of these
men became major players in the establishment of
the early church, and I don't think it's an accident that Jesus
had them as a part of his micro group, okay.
All right.
What are we going to do next will we're gonna
meet in our micro groups. I'm I know there are
two brand new people here tonight, and I'm trying
to find where you are and I cannot so in a minute when we break into
our micro groups, if you're new and you want me to help you find one and
come meet with me down here and I'll get you I'll get
you hooked up with a micro group. Okay, let's pray together and then
we'll break up.
Father thank you so much for something as important as
disciple making thank you for allowing me
to serve on a church. That's made disciple making a
high priority Lord. Give me the wisdom to
know how to inspire these people to be involved in
something that we life-changing for eternity
and it's in Jesus name. I pray amen.